cela fait bientôt un an un an qu'ils
n'ont plus vu le tableau noir
nous demandons un retour en classe en
présentiel
après une année sans mettre les pieds à
l'école les conséquences psychologiques
et physiques sont importantes tout comme
sur le travail ainsi que les familles un
million et demi d'enfants ont abandonné
leur scolarité
depuis le début de la pandémie tous les
niveaux sont concernés de la maternelle
à l'université
aucune salle de classe n'a pu ouvrir
sauf dérogation
ce mardi les argentins se sont donc
réunis devant le ministère de
l'éducation à buenos aires pour
protester contre une fermeture qui n'en
finit plus je me sens loin de mes
camarades de cours c'était la dernière
chance pour moi de créer des liens avec
eux et honnêtement cela m'affecte
énormément d'un point de vue social en
argentine 6 enfants sur 10 vivent sous
le seuil de pauvreté
ainsi les moyens mis en place comme
l'école à distance via internet ne font
qu'accroître les inégalités
si bien que 80 % des parents se disent
inquiets pour le niveau scolaire de
leurs enfants
3 million et demi d'enfants non pas une
connexion suffisante et ne pourront pas
suivre les cours
ils sont déjà six mille cinq cents rien
que dans la ville de buenos ars mais il
n'y a aucun chiffre sur la région de la
capitale
le gouvernement ne veut pas les fournir
la vérité c'est qu'il est dépassé on a
un gouvernement qui ne répond jamais à
nos demandes et qui voit l'éducation
comme quelque chose qu'on peut repousser
à plus tard
alors que l'om est conseillé de garder
les salles de classes ouvertes au moment
de la deuxième vague
l'incompréhension est totale pour les
argentins surtout quand leurs voisins
prennent le risque de rouvrir comme le
chili depuis le 5 octobre dernier sans
que la situation sanitaire ne s'aggrave
pour autant pris à partie le ministre de
l'éducation a voulu réagir
[Musique]
il est impératif que toutes les
provinces met en place un retour dans
les classes nous souhaitons promouvoir
le retour des cours en présentiel
initiée par buenos aires le 17 février
prochain
mais cela dans des conditions sûres nous
devons travailler main dans la main avec
toutes les juridictions pour assurer un
retour dans les classes avec le plus de
précaution possible à cette crise
sanitaire s'y ajoute une autre
économique cette fois sujet à une
inflation galopante le pays connaît
actuellement une hausse de 74 % du prix
de la viande
alors qu'il doit déjà restructurer une
dette avoisinant les 90 % de son pib
le président alberto fernandez à mes
mises en place un impôt kovy destinés
aux plus riches pour faire face
s'agissant des vaccins l'argentine a
lancé sa campagne le 29 décembre dernier
et doit encore recevoir 19,4 millions de
doses de vaccins d'ici fin février + 5
en option
peuplée de 44 millions d'habitants
l'argentine a pour l'heure enregistré
près de deux millions de cas qu vide 19
pour cinquante mille décès et pour ne
rien arranger le pays vient d'identifier
le variant brésilien sur son sol